les traces physiques de l'attentât de
mardi dernier sont est facile de la
synagogue night aura art 9 mai pour tous
ceux qui s'y sont entassés aujourd'hui
pour une cérémonie à la mémoire des cinq
personnes qui sont mortes le choc
demeure entier la douleur vive se lit
sur les visages et elle s'entend par les
chants de prières
qu'ils soient les payeurs je voulais
partager la douleur et appuyer les
familles et yahoo va une somme et
branding la jeune israélo canadienne est
aussi déchiré partisan du dialogue et le
croient encore à une paix négociée
mais pour le moment elle vu surtout
obtenir son permis de port d'armes et se
joindre à une milice bénévoles pour
appuyer les policiers il y à des
extrémistes radicaux avec qui il est
impossible de négocier alors je dois
agir pour me protéger et protéger mon
peuple dit elle le jeune israël kassab
lui aussi venue prier n'a pas trouvé le
réconfort qu'ils cherchaient ils à
réponse du gouvernement israélien
l'attentât ne l'appelle pas plus le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin pour
punir les responsables
fatin ils sont trop on dit sont trop
plus avec leur côté tue tous les
responsables du bain de sang la
synagogue eux sont morts abattus par la
police dans le quartier arabe de jabel
mukaber à jérusalem est
la photo des deux cousins race and et
hoda abu-jamal flottent au dessus des
rues presque désertes bloqué par ces
blocs de ciment
les traces d'affrontements récents entre
les jeunes du quartier la police sont
partout et on sent bien que ça peut
reprendre à tout instant
les gens du quartier viennent offrir
leurs condoléances à la famille qui
vient de recevoir un avis de démolition
de la maison familiale
un châtiment contreversé réactivée par
israël au cours des derniers jours en
réaction récents attentats
d'ici 48 heures les services de sécurité
viendront les punir e pour les gestes
des leurs les leurs les auteurs de
l'attaqué de mardi dont les causes
restent toujours entre les mains des
autorités israéliennes
ça aussi une forme de punition et
fournissait des tours bordeaux
si le gouvernement nous rend les deux
corps et revient sur sa décision de
démolir la maison je crois que le calme
va revenir des cils démoli la maison et
garde les corps alors ça va dégénérer 17
ami de la famille
et c'est bien là ce que tout le monde
prenne l'atmosphère à jérusalem est
chargé chargé de la peur et de la
méfiance des uns de l'animosité et de la
haine des autres
dans un tel climat de tensions la
moindre provocation pourrait bien être
l'étincelle qui fasse en sorte que tout
s'embrase ici marie ève bédard
radio-canada jérusalem